what's up guys welcome to screen junkies
so we all grew up on cartoon characters
they made us laugh there's so much fun
and they aroused us today we're gonna
talk about the hottest cartoon
characters that's right you heard the
topic correctly we have a fun panel to
talk about this topic first you know I'm
from geek and sundry and the Nerdist mr.
a stereoscope knows thanks for having me
here one of my favorite topics so happy
to be here she is lovely and delightful
funny from Parks and Rec Alison Becker
thanks for having me I'm excited to talk
about boning some drawings first off
right off the bat I want to take Jessica
Rabbit off the table so let's talk about
possibly the most famous group of
hotties Disney Princesses that's like
flipping through a Victoria's Secret
catalogs actually I get too brave but
before that it's just fantastic it's a
panoply I guess I would want to start
with Ariel from The Little Mermaid
strong faster than all of our childhood
dreams
she doesn't have lady parts she into
this lady part what is that a Gil maybe
she doesn't have the lady parts
downstairs but she's got him up top I
just like to make note of how quickly
this discussion has gotten awfully
creepy just perfectly
sorry guys Alison I'm gonna go nice and
classic on this one and say Snow White
don't forget that of course my white
skin the dark hair she's very hot great
cause she lives in the woods with tiny
little sex slaves like she's clearly in
different kinky stuff yeah and she's
down to be made out with when she's dead
which for necrophiliacs out there is a
huge plus I want to go a little bit
underdog here and go with Esmerelda from
Hunchback of Notre oh yes if she's
willing to spend time with a hunchback
you know she's good to go
she has very low standards which is kind
of all I'm looking for personally haha
that's like the number one thing so we
hit that major category of Disney
Princesses now I know you guys have each
picked out some of your faves okay we
know we have female viewers out there
and Alison you in fact are a female last
time I checked great so we're also going
to talk about male care
ders as well Mysterio's Brock Samson
from The Venture Brothers he's tall he's
ripped and he doesn't talk too much
three things women consistently failed
to find in me look I think he's good for
like a bang but not someone I'm looking
to marry Brock Samson I think we could
all agree good for an F yeah in the car
um I actually like to marry someone like
the Pink Panther she's like really cool
and suave he's definitely somehow linked
to some expensive jewel and also has his
hand in the insulation business so he's
got a nice if I were to marry anybody it
would probably be Pat man I think he
would use his detective skills to like
plan the perfect date wait Pacman's a
detective Batman oh I thought you said
Pac Man hold on wait a minute like as
you said Pac Man I was like well he
loves snacks like pretzels and cherries
and keys so we probably bang Brock
Samson we'd marry Bruce Wayne who do we
kill maybe like Donatello Verma Ninja
Turtles Donatello
yeah or he-man he's too much of a
goody-goody I don't I think he man is
probably good for at least let's go to
uh to the women Alison let's start with
you who's a female cartoon character
that you think is hella fine Wonder
Woman on star spangled panties yeah
she's super American patriotic plus
she'll role play in that invisible Jeff
well I could join the invisible
mile-high club
it's a Wonder Woman for Alison I think a
pretty cool pick would be the esurance
girl the assurance girl crosses the
galaxy and fights monsters to save you
money the East surance girl
what a terrible answer oh you oh if the
esurance girls like in the annals of
cartoon history you go with the Essure
as serious commenters come to my defense
if you think the esurance girls is a
trafficking i do your weigh in on the
comments below area yours right you guys
realize you're shouting over pretend
characters right welcome to the screen
junkies show okay so guys now we're
gonna move into a speed round I'm gonna
throw out some combinations and I want
you to tell me who's hotter
let's start with scooby-doo Daphne and
Velma
gotta go Velma yeah I would go Velma
although I'd also throw in shaggy
because he's got a dog and access
tomorrow gem or josie and the pussycats
I'm sorry a stereo host I gotta go Jim
gem is so hot that you're passing up the
opportunity to be with three girls yeah
Smurfette or gadget from the Rescue
Rangers that's gadget the mouse yeah
just like your best friend tomboy girl
next door which Smurfette is friends
with a unicorn that will grant her three
wishes over the course of her lifetime
gotta go Smurfette oh who do you like
out of these three Marge Simpson Lois
from Family Guy or Cartman's mom this is
actual this is a real thing what about
Lana from Archer or doctor girlfriend
from venture where oh I gotta go with
dr. girlfriend specifically dr. mrs. the
monarch ooh
reporter showdown Lois Lane and April
O'Neill I'm gonna put April O'Neill in
front of most but I think Lois Lane just
for Shirley sorry I gotta go April
O'Neill Lois Lane is so dumb that she
doesn't know Superman sits across the
desk from her April O'Neill knows the
turtles secret identity yeah they're
giant turtles yeah do Anila ice write a
song about Lois Lane No
case closed boom we've gone round and
round with this now I want a definitive
answer what is your ultimate cartoon sex
tape I'm gonna say Smurfette and Brock
Sampson because the size thing there is
crazy I'm gonna go with the Pink Panther
with all three of the Chipettes the
female Chipmunks I mean that's gonna get
like a bazillion hits at the very least
I would click on the free preview of
that video mine I gave it some thought
we talked about Ariel earlier
what about Ariel and Aquaman that would
be ridiculous I don't know
would turn me on but I would definitely
watch the like education and here's all
I'm saying
Aquaman has the ability to summon fish
oh my god that's gonna be an orgy the
size of the sea Oh
Nemo we'll get in on that absolutely so
what would your ultimate cartoon sex
tape be leave a hot and steamy answer in
the comment section below
best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank my super
delightful panel for talking about weird
stuff today a stereoscope knows Thank
You Alison Becker thank you and I want
to thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye